what did you make it what did you make
of the deal that the Chinese and the
u.s. just struck is it is it a good
thing the fact we're talking is a very
good thing okay you know I've said
recently we've been talking past each
other for quite some time the fact that
we will agree to come to the table and
really dig into this topic is really a
big step forward you know there's a lot
of pessimist about whether wheel will
make any real progress but the fact that
we're at the table together is very
promising what's the role of governments
in this versus the role of rogue
individuals or rogue organizations a
good question you know we saw a lot of
individual attacker as many years ago
we've done as an international community
we've done a quite a good job I think
enforcing kind of the individual
attackers out unfortunately been
replaced by the organized groups
nation-states organized crime or just
well structured kind of splinter groups
they're much more sophisticated they're
certainly persistent much more difficult
for us to deal with so if I'm a company
with IP I want to protect do I feel
safer now that we're talking I do I just
I'm happy that we're talking but do I
actually feel safer that with you know
there's not sufficient evidence today to
say you should feel safer I mean right I
think we need to be vigilant we need to
really think through our defenses and do
all of the things that as an
international community we've been
talking about to protect you know very
sensitive intellectual property and
trade sigir I don't see any relief in
sight in a near-term Braun has anybody
done any work on what the economic costs
globally is because now we all know what
the problems are we all know where we're
vulnerable we all know it's very
difficult to protect ourselves but what
worked in the final analysis how much
does this cost the global economy yeah
it's a great course what's the debit
yeah yeah fantastic question i'm not
sure we know i mean there have been some
studies that try to generally kind of
you know find out what this may cost
that the problem we have is a lot of
organizations won't report this
information it's very sensitive
potentially impacts their brand
significantly so there's many companies
that just will not report if they've had
a loss or
so there's a there's a there's a big
part of the data set that's actually
missing today so I don't think we we
know just yet is that the information
sharing that you're you would like
businesses to go about that sharing
we're not exactly but there may be some
value in that as well what really would
what we're proposing is information
sharing that would allow another
organization to potentially detect and
prevent an attack so a very specific
information about what we call
indicators a compromise or various
tactics this is very relevant very
timely information probably have had
today and information sharing is that
information is made available oftentimes
weeks and months later its of no value
to me if I see an attack this evening I
need to take I need to characterize that
you need to get that out to peers you
know other cloud service providers in my
instance as fast as possible so I'm
talking sharing tactical information in
the matter of minutes and hours as
opposed to today's practice is sharing
information in weeks and months it's not
common then they go off to they might go
off to you or business like yours and
then they go after others exactly
similar way and I think you know we
talked about this underground economy
you know so if we want to play that game
we got to drive their costs up right so
you take a what they call a zero-day
attack the attack that's never been seen
before you know right now we're not
sharing information they can use that
attack many different times let's go
exactly very much so yeah so if we can
if we can characterize that attack very
quickly share that information the next
time they go to use that attack and fail
so now they've got to go back to the
drawing board reinvest in some cases
they begin to aggregate themselves and
become a much bigger signature a much
bigger target and the international
community has a much better chance of
actually seeing them what does your cost
curve look like well how much do you
have to but what's the average age of a
person that comes and interviews for a
job with your business and what's the
cut of inflation rate in wages that
you're having to pay yeah well the
Christian flate rate is high because it
right now there's a there's a lack of
supply of trained and experienced cyber
professionals so they can they can
command you know much much higher
salaries I think from from an age
distribution it varies we were talking
previously that you know in the past
we'd have to go back and higher kind of
the young hackers sort of speaking up
refer to them as black hats I don't
think that's true any longer I mean is
it the universities and corporations are
really producing some some high quality
cyber talent and so now we're seeing a
range of yes in some cases young you
know out of school but I think there's a
lot of good experience people that maybe
had some government experience or have
been in the corporate world for 10 to 20
years that really are extremely valuable
so that that that kind of dynamic is
changing a little bit problem is though
we still have a deficit in trained
security professionals and so we're all
competing pretty aggressively for the
best of the best